you
casa kalma fever as the new leader of
the Nobel Committee you have said today
that what has happened in the Indonesia
should serve as an example for many
other countries how important has this
element been for the committee now it
has it is of course always important
when we want to to put the light on a
laureate having done good work that this
could serve as an example for others I
think you will see that sort of a red
thread through the whole history of the
nobel peace prize please tell us more
exactly what is this peace prize
laureate this organization the National
Dialogue quartets is comprised of or has
been comprised of four civil society
organizations at the moment I would call
it a make-or-break moment in the
Tunisian development after the jasmine
revolution they saw the need to act as
one and to stand on the broad values
they together represent and with this
having a moral authority in not only
guiding but pushing the development in
the right direction and they achieved
that Tunisia today has a pluralistic
society with the fundamental rights for
everyone is the decision by the nobel
committee also a message for the whole
arabic world it is a message both to the
region and to the rest of the world but
of course the out of the Arab Spring
countries Tunisia is
the only one where the development has
proven so successful even though there
are still challenges but we want to
point to the fact that it is possible
for Isla Vista and secular political
movements to work together in the best
interest of the people and that civil
society organizations can play an
important role in the democracy
development and create a peaceful
development based on dialogue and
consensus these are our main messages
which criteria in the noble enough
Annabel's will is most relevant to this
year's decision well as we state in the
announcement text the broad national
dialogue this quartet achieved is in its
function very close to those peace
Congress's Alfred Nobel speaker in his
will what was most difficult during the
process ended up when today's decision
now I cannot tell you anything from the
discussions we have had with 273
candidates there it's always difficult
to choose but we are totally agreed on
the results I have presented to you
today well on us that you are the new
Secretary of the Nobel Committee how
will you characterize the work done by
the committee well it's been very
inspiring to follow the discussions and
take part in the elaborations I think it
shows five very committed members who
take this job very very seriously and do
their homework so it's been been been
very inspiring to follow but what kind
of a peace price is this is a human
rights prize or whatever is it I think
this is the price that establishes the
relevance of democracy
human rights to peace could this yes the
Peace Prize laureates could it be
compared to any other Peace Prize
laureates yes of course they can we are
speaking of other candidates working in
the fields of democracy human rights
then but still it's also quite unique in
that is what the chairman of the
committee pointed out that there are
some very unique specific things about
the Tunisian experience and they were
really what the committee wanted to
focus upon consider mafia have you been
in contact already with one or more of
the members of this quartet no we will
contact them directly after this press
events and but they have been informed
by by others when was the decision taken
was it taken early in the process or
late in the process now as always we
stress ourselves in the committee to
underline that you never make the
decision until the last meeting you have
to have an open mind but of course we do
not have 273 candidates anymore on our
table when we come to the last meeting
so well it's been a normal process it's
always a difficult process but we are
very satisfied by they'll come well
O'Neil star the nobel peace prize is by
far the most prestigious peace prize in
the world and this decision by the
committing what kind of image will this
decision have on the on the peace prize
in the future I don't think it will
alter very much the existing image but
it will of course confirm that the
committee believes strongly believes
that there are close connections between
basic rights democracy and peace
cause a good movie ever what makes your
mostly proud today well I'm proud to see
that there are candidates like the
quartet's existing the work they have
been doing in a very difficult time for
their country and what they have
obtained by this work i think i'm
looking forward to meet the
representatives of the four Tet's when
they come to oslo in december will it be
one of four members coming here no it's
it's one laureate that's very clear but
if they are represented who will
represent them we have still not
discussed the details of that but we
will find solutions to this but they
were four participants in this one
organization thank you so much both of
you